People in the audience have been sending me
more and more of these video clips of Michael.
Sure.
Our great friend Michael Shaw speaking to
Trump supporters at recent rallies as well
as other reporters.
And I want to play a few of them and talk
a little bit about it.
We did a story a few months ago about a group
of uneducated white women who voted for Trump
in 2016 and being interviewed on CNN.
And it was really bad.
And I said at the time, this may not be politically
correct.
This may not be polite, but we have to come
to terms with the reality that many voters
have no clue.
It's unfortunate.
It's not nice to say in these terms, maybe,
but the point is that they have just as much
of a right to vote as anybody else.
And many of them do vote.
We have to understand that we now have some
interviews done over the last.
Five or so days with various Trump supporters
at different events.
And it's really bad.
It's just as bad.
Before we get to the Michael Shaw clips, let's
start with one from CNN.
CNN asking Trump rally goers over the last
few days.
Why aren't you wearing a mask?
And it instantly turns into wildly debunked
conspiracy theories.
I have one with me.
It's my prerogative where they say.
I have a hard time understanding people when
they go on.
So that's why I don't work.
You can hear me right now.
I can hear you.
Because there's no call.
It's a it's a pandemic created to destroy
the United States of America.
The president said there is a virus, a virus,
and that it is.
That's his opinion.
The truth is, the CDC said less than 10000
people die from it.
The other one hundred and ninety thousand
have to at two point six or two point eight
other mortality covered was created to destroy
the U.S..
That other conspiracy theory, by the way,
about the real number of deaths is 9000.
We've already debunked that.
It's been widely debunked.
But the mess.
The important thing to glean is even though
it was debunked weeks ago, you still have
these rally goers who probably do vote.
I mean, I think that if you go to a rally
or you're almost certainly voting, they still
are repeating these conspiracy theories.
And then it continues now taking sort of a
more religious approach about not wearing
a mask.
I'm not afraid.
The good Lord takes care of me.
If I die, I got to get this country where
mass stay inside for another year.
So that's really bad.
Then we have these great clips from our friend
Michael.
Sure.
Are doing these interviews for T.Y.
T and first folks going right into socialism.
He says he's not a socialist, but all of his
ideas sound like socialist ideas.
And everybody around him are like socialists.
And they all support that.
And he I think that as soon as he's in office,
he will start pushing socialism.
If he was in office there, the devil, they
got a lot of Satan in him.
They're out for their own good.
They have no interest in the United States
of America.
And the day they're who's the they the Democrats,
Biden, Pelosi, all of them are just going
to let evil in him.
They're not in the best interests of the United
States of America.
I support Trump because he's not a socialist.
I'm a foreigner in America.
I live in two socialist countries and I want
nothing to do with socialism.
Do you see Joe Biden as a socialist?
The people that are handling him are socialist.
Yes.
There are no socialist ideas from Joe Biden.
Now, what's what I've said before?
I get criticized for being a socialist, even
though I'm not and for not being a socialist
by people who want me to be a socialist.
Many on the left wish Joe Biden were a socialist.
He's not.
There's nothing socialistic about Joe Biden's
policies.
Here are supporters confronted by Michael.
Sure.
With Donald Trump's comments about soldiers
who died in combat being losers and suckers,
we suspected that many of them would simply
say Trump didn't really say it.
And that's exactly what many of them said.
Ridiculous.
The media.
All the lies they put out there are ridiculous.
No president is going to make a comment like
that.
Definitely.
Donald Trump, our president, is not going
to make a comment like that.
Look what he's done with the veterans.
He's done more for their medical care than
any other president, probably in the history
of the country.
So absolutely false and immediately come out
with something false.
Every day they continue to lie and lie and
lie.
And people are a lot of people are aware that
if John Kelly did say that happened, what
would you think?
That guy would disregard it?
Because I know there's over 25 people that
said it didn't occur.
Doesn't fit with your world view, doesn't
match your preexisting beliefs.
Well, then just say it didn't happen.
Here's another one.
It's all a lie.
He loves the veterans.
And I'd rather have him 10 times than I am.
But bad more.
Goodness.
Look, sell our country to China.
Everybody else.
Single dollar from.
That's all he's ever done since he's been
in office as.
As a military veteran.
Some of the stuff that's come out about what
the president allegedly said about, you know,
Americans in cemeteries and whatnot and what
he said about John McCain, a naval man.
Has that given you pause at all?
Has not.
He has said some things that I say things
off the spur of moments that I go back.
What did I say that for that last guy?
Interestingly, taking the approach not of
denying that Trump said it, but denying that
he meant it.
And then this last one is really special,
Michael.
Michael Shaw from T.Y..
He really doing a great job on these Trump
supporters.
Asked, what will you do if Donald Trump loses?
Will you accept the result of Joe Biden with
No.
Under any circumstance?
Now was a.
Because it's.
Lies and deceit and corruption.
So this is one strategy.
And again, this is the importance of paying
attention to the stories.
Trump tells their ridiculous stories.
But they work.
They stick to people.
If Biden wins, it would be fake preemptively
saying it'll be fake.
If Biden wins.
Take a look at this next one.
I'll be down on my knees praying a lot harder,
praying for Joe Biden success or praying for
four years from now.
Replacing Joe Biden.
Praying for God to help us.
President Biden.
That can't happen.
I can't even think about that because he does
not like America.
He's a racist.
Now, that's racist.
If you want to look at someone despises the
black man, the black woman, he looks out for
himself.
He's a crook.
His son is a crook.
He's a criminal.
What happens if Donald Trump loses?
Do you have a fear for the country of Donald
Trump?
You're nodding your head.
OK.
You got involved.
I'll ask both of you.
We actually have plans to move to Panama because
it's a city or it's a country that allows
Americans to move there and to actually own
firearms there.
I mean, if they trust us enough to own firearms,
as you know, people with legal right to be
in their country.
You know, it seems like a place that's not
planning to do something terrible to their
people.
But if he wins, it means the Democratic machine
has won in some of the illegal tactics that,
you know, the voter fraud.
I, I think that if he loses, they come after
all of us supporters.
Yeah.
Biden is actually the racist.
Now, I know the reaction from many of us when
we watch this stuff, when we hear these clips
is disgust.
How are these our fellow Americans?
How is it possible to have such uneducated,
ignorant people in the United States?
This is the result of our education system.
This is the result of religious indoctrination.
This is the result of decades of anti intellectual
ism going back to media.
In a sense, anti intellectual ism has been
around for hundreds of years.
But certainly prominently in the Republican
Party to Reagan.
And, you know, this imaginary welfare queen
with 12 kids and a Cadillac and whatever the
story was.
Everything we've been talking about, this
is the outcome that we are seeing.
We are seeing it front and center and it is
very ugly.
Check out one other one here.
I've actually considered leaving the country,
moving to South America or something like
that.
Something like that happens.
I've had neighbors moved when Hillary was
running against President Trump because he
was convinced Hillary is going to win.
He sold everything and moved to Panama and
said, I'm thinking, you know, my ancestors
did that back in 1992 when he left Germany,
said I would hurt for my grandchildren.
Why South America, I wonder?
Most of those governments in South America
are left wing governments.
By most standards.
Now, if the guy likes authoritarians, I guess
he could look at moving to Venezuela.
But I don't think that's the idea of a better
place for most Trump voters.
But really, really stunning stuff.
And we have to resist it.
You know, there's this thing that will often
happen on the left where we start kind of
moralizing and talking about, you know, these
poor, stupid people and blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah.
They vote.
And I think that we really need to see them.
It's much more productive to see these folks
as victims rather than perpetrators.
They are victims of an education system that
has failed.
They are victims of, in some cases, religious
indoctrination.
They are victims of a lack of media literacy
and a corporate media that thrives on salaciousness
and so on and so forth.
It's far more productive to do that than to
look down at them from some moral high ground,
which I think is both unjustified in many
ways and completely counterproductive.
Let me know your interpretation if you disagree
with mine.
And we'll have more of these clips on the
show, Instagram page
at
David Pakman.
Show
on Instagram